có đăng phán giữ Mỹ về Iran đang đối mặt với nhiều thích thức lớn khi ai bên duy trị lập trường khác biệt với các bạn địa của lỗi.
Thao các ngon tiền của tế, Tey Rhan để sốt kiế hoạch hoạch hoạch bình mười điểm, bao gồm giám sát yêu biệt thông ốc,
yêu cầu ở sinh tình rất lực lượng khỏi chung đăng và chấm rất khó đồng cuộc sử trong lại các lượng đồng mình của Iran.
Firm Mỹ chưa chức nhận cái điều khoản này, dù tổng thống đơn trang kơi đây là cơ sở đi đăng phán.
Nhà chẳng cũng chưa sang Iran có thể từ bỏ chính chính u ren yu mâm sau,
sau phía tế Rhan cũng chưa sang nhận, một điểm bắt đầu lớn là tình hình gạy libang,
nơi các cuộc không kích quý xe rail làm giác tăng cân thẳng.
Mọi trường Iran đã bắt sợi chi cạnh máo của tế giúp khỏi lần bán,
nơi các cuộc tấn công tiếp diễn, cho khi phòng tổng thống Mỹ trên đe bàn sẵn định thật thận không bao gồm libang.
Theo ông, Mà xuất khá lý tụ đại xử Phà Kistan,
thành đống của sự buổi xe rail đào làm suy yếu tính chiến đàn phán,
nhà phân tế xa khăn tại Washington nhận định,
kiểu nêm tên là rau cảnh lương nhất, khiến khăn năng đặt thật thận thân dẹt trong hắn hạp giữ Mỹ
bệnh Iran là rất thấp.